>> Tucker: AMERICAN MEDIA
INCIDENT FEDERAL TO CREATING
THE PUTIN CAMPAIGN COLLUDED
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
OUTLETS CLAIMING THE WHOLE
THING NEVER HAPPENED.
THEY DIDN'T CLAIM THAT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THEY HAVEN'T
GROWN UNINTERESTED IN THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THEY TREAT THAT
INVESTIGATION SACRED EVEN
THOUGH THE 13 DEMOCRATS,
THREE INDEPENDENCE AND NO
REPUBLICANS UNLESS YOU
INCLUDE MUELLER HIMSELF.
LEE SMITH IS A SENIOR FELLOW
AT THE HUDSON INSTITUTE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
LEE, WHATEVER YOU THINK THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION OR
WHATEVER YOU ANTICIPATE WE
ARE GOING TO LEARN FROM IT,
YOU CAN'T DENY THAT THE
PRESS ALLEGED IN EFFECT
COLLUSION FOR MONTHS.
>> YES.
LITTLE MACHINE
LITTLE MUCHINE
LITTLE MUCH TE
LITTLE MUCH TO PRETEND THEY
DIDN'T.
>> WENT ON BEFORE THE
ELECTION AND WELL BEFORE THE
STORY WE ATTRIBUTED OR
BELIEVED TO HAVE COME FROM
THE STEELE DOSSIER.
THAT WAS YAHOO NEWS PIECE
AND MOTHER JONES PIECE.
THIS STARTED IN JULY.
IF YOU LOOK, THERE IS A
CAMPAIGN INFORMATION
OPERATION.
THE PRESS ALREADY GOING ON
FOR STEVE PUBLICATION AND
AMERICAN PRESS GOING AFTER
DIFFERENT FIGURES IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN CARTER PAGE.
LIKE THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
BRA ZIN SKI OR KISSINGER.
IF I WERE COVERING THE AUTO
INDUSTRY AND COVERING EVERY
TALKING POINT GM SENT ME
THAT WOULD NOT MAKE ME A
JOURNALIST.
THAT WOULD MAKE ME BASICALLY
AN EMPLOYEE OF G.M.
IT SEEMS LIKE REPORTERS ARE
DOING THAT WITH THE INTEL
COMMUNITY AND WITH THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
>> YES.
IT'S ACTUALLY SHAMEFUL.
THE IDEA THAT THE AMERICAN
PRESS IS WORKING, HAS BEEN
WORKING FOR A WHILE WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
TAKING LEAKS FROM THEM.
MANY OF THESE LEAKS, OF
COURSE, ARE ILLEGAL LIKE
WITH THE LEAK OF MICHAEL
FLYNN, EXACTLY, THE WAY THAT
THEY ARE WORKING AND
INFORMATION OPERATION ALONG
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY THAT IT'S A
HORRIBLE THING TO HAVE
HAPPENED TO THE PRESS.
AND THE PRESS DID IT TO
THEMSELVES.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU HURT
YOURSELF AS A JOURNALIST IF
YOU ARE NOT SKEPTICAL.
JOURNALISTS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
LIBERAL.
I GET IT.
I HAVE DONE IT MY WHOLE
LIFE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: SKEPTICISM WAS
THE THING THAT TIED US
TOGETHER.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THAT.
>> A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
HAVE HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE PRESS
LEANING TOWARD THE LEFT
WHICH IS USUALLY AGAIN,
THAT'S THE WAY THE PRESS HAS
ALWAYS BEEN.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
>> SOMETHING DIFFERENT
HAPPENED HERE.
I DO BELIEVE THERE WILL BE A
PRICE TO PAY.
I DO BELIEVE THAT DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ONCE THE RUSSIAN
NARRATIVE MORE AND MORE.
ONCE THE DOSSIER NONSENSE
HAS GONE THROUGH, I BELIEVE
PEOPLE WILL LOOK BACK AND
THEY WILL SAY WHAT HAPPENED
HERE?
WHAT DID THE PRESS DO?
WE ENJOYED IT LIKE A BUNCH
OF CHOCOLATES.
WE GOT A RUSH FROM IT NOW WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
TRUST THEM ANYMORE.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE UPSHOT OF THIS I KNOW
YOU ARE NOT HERE TO DISCUSS
POLITICS.
I CAN'T RESIST.
CAN YOU RUN A MIDTERM
ELECTION ON RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
I KNOW WHOLE CAPABLE
STORIES.
>> I DON'T SEE HOW.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
RUN AGAINST VLADIMIR PUTIN?
NO I THINK IT'S MUCH MORE
LIKELY THE REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO END UP RUNNING
AGAINST ADAM SCHIFF.
END UP RUNNING AGAINST
PEOPLE.
RUN AGAINST PEOPLE, SENIOR
DEMOCRATIC FIGURES WHO MAY
HAVE PLAYED A VERY
DESTRUCTIVE ROLE IN THE 2016
ELECTIONS AND I THINK IF WE
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
INVESTIGATIONS ON THE HILL
THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IT,
LOOKS LIKE SENIOR DEMOCRATS
WHO HAVE DONE SOME VERY BAD
THINGS, I THINK IT DOESN'T
LOOK GREAT FOR THEM HEADING
INTO 2000 --
>> Tucker: IF I WERE A
DEMOCRAT AND WANTED TO TALK